[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solution this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life your
money your work and your relationships
the phone number to jump in for your
question is AAA
88255 225 toll-free number I'm Ken
Coleman joined by the incomparable
George camel with that's k m l if you're
keeping score at home uh I love that we
were on a national network recently we
shall not name them and a well-known
host called you caml KL and I thought I
think it's regal it sounds nice it's
sounded great but I'm over there we were
on opposite ends of this little Riser or
whatever Y and I'm trying not to get the
church Giggles I know uh so I wanted to
make sure that everybody knows your name
is camel it's like the animal people
think it's going to be weird but I
appreciate that Ken for calling it out
uh you have my favorite denim jacket on
today it's like uniform only when we're
together it tickles Ken when I wear
denim it does and so let's get to it you
ready to help some people let's do this
all right we're going to Courtney who's
joining us in Raleigh North Carolina
Courtney how can we
help hey uh thank you for taking my call
you bet um so we just um completed a
very significant home repair a very
unexpected for about
$270,000 oh my gosh hold the phone what
did it burn down and you rebuilt
it um we were actually victims of fraud
um oh no there was significant water
damage termite damage um a lot of a lot
of issues that were hidden also they
sold you a house that was just a
disaster F and you didn't know it is
that what I'm
hearing yes oh my gosh but 270 Grand did
you just gut this thing down to the
studs and start
over basically yes oh bless your heart
oh my gosh and you have no recourse
here uh we actually do um we are
pursuing that path um but we are of the
mindset that we are in control of our
destiny and so um we want to you know
consider levers that we can pull to
accelerate getting out of this mess um
we were lucky to be able to cash flow
about
$50,000 of it um but we had to take out
some um some loans a 401k loan and a
home equity loan um to just get through
it so my question is um should we sell
the house and be able to accelerate um
This Mess by um probably a year year and
a half half so what is your total
Consumer Debt put the the home equity
loan aside the 401K loan aside what you
have any other Consumer
Debt we do so we did stupid and went to
um buy two cars before all of this
before knowing anything about the house
so um we have a student loan for n Grand
and then two cars for 45 Grand so a
total of about 54 in Consumer Debt in
addition to the 401K loan and the home
Equity okay and what is remaining on the
401K loan the home equity
loan uh 12,000 on the 401K loan and
97,000 on the heok is that on top of
your
mortgage yes oh dear lord okay what's
left on the
mortgage uh
350,000 and what's your household
income um it's about 200,000 okay good
we've got a good shovel to work with
here but goodness we got a of debt so
what could this house sell for now that
you fixed it up I imagine you did not
Roi in the least bit on
this we did not um we weren't even
considering selling it at that time but
we um met with our Realtor and he thinks
we can get 600 for
it okay so you sell it for 600 you get
rid of the 401K loan the home equity
loan the mortgage you you'd get rid of
all of your debt completely and still
have a little bit left over to start
with correct yeah okay I mean here's the
thing I selling a home is a last ditch
effort for me but this feels like one of
those situations where I go you guys
aren't going to be able to breathe at
night and I imagine the emotional
turmoil you've experienced just
rebuilding this place it's kind of
giving you the
ick it is especially my husband I think
there's more the mathematics makees
sense behind it I think we're just
dealing with the emotional side of
should we sell it and just move on I
mean does he resent the house cuz I
resent this house and I've only known
about it for four
minutes he very much resents then I I
almost always agree with George and
that's going to swell his head I
disagree that this is last ditch in this
situation I think this is option A I
would sell the house oh okay I see
you're saying okay Clean Slate yeah it's
been a massive pain in their rear it's
just nightmarish as you say to try to
dig out of this they can but why not
just get free and clear of it all and if
you got to rent for a year you got an
income where you can get up a nice down
payment you go into it fresh and you go
we learned a lot and this is one of
those sometimes you win sometimes you
learn and they don't lose if they sell
and they get out and they're so much
more educated but they're free of all of
this uh I don't the hardest part is
going to be freeing ourselves of the
guilt the shame the stupid tax the sunk
CA fallacy all of that is going to be
the hardest part the numbers we can deal
with you guys have a great income you
can clear your debt and still walk away
with probably what 50
Grand I would do it tonight I have sign
in the yard like within five minutes of
this phone call if it were me uh this is
a no-brainer is that where you all were
leaning before you
called uh yes because the home can know
longer give us what we want we bought it
before having kids and now we have a
daughter and the location just isn't you
know there there's not a lot of younger
families in our area so um now there's
extra this is one of many reasons
according for the benefit of the
audience can you explain how this fraud
happened did you not get an inspection
how did you get swindled
here we did have an inspection it was a
result of flippers um coming in and
flipping the property they had done some
work on it um but we later found out
that they did not do honest work on it
and really tried to spend as little as
possible to just make sure it didn't um
it didn't you know fall down before the
sale um so but the inspector caught
nothing the inspector was like this
house is in tiptop shape go for it yes
the inspector needs to be sued at this
point that's insane have you gotten back
in touch with the inspector and said
here's what we had to
do we have yes what did they have to say
about
it they've pretty much thrown their
hands in the air and said that they're
not liable is it stuff that they
couldn't see in the general inspection
meaning behind drywall so you discovered
it only when you started doing some
Renovations yeah pulling back the siding
and realizing what was underneath it
okay uh not to defend the the inspector
but Stacy and I had this happen in the
home R in now George you've been there
that front room we were putting shelves
in and and so we saw some mold on the
drywall underneath some trim and so not
everything can be seen like that so
again not trying to defend the inspector
but sometimes I can happen there was a
leak where rainwater was getting in a
small crevice in an area of brick up
against the house anyway the point is
that can happen I'm so sorry Courtney
but uh Hey listen I'm glad they that
they that they can get out of it so
thanks for the call more Ramy show
coming
[Music]
up if you're like most people your home
is your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can compl completely change your space
and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their
100% satisfaction guarantee and shipping
is always free Cy blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now to
get up to 50% off that's blinds.com
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramy show where we
talk to you for you about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships if you want to win in
those areas we're here for you it's a
free phone call at
8825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman I'll talk with
you about your work situation can you
make the income you want and the impact
that you dream about the answer is yes
can you do it while you're in the baby
steps yes I'll walk through any of your
work or income related questions today
and then George Campell my friend and
colleague will walk you through the baby
steps and your money questions and uh
George and I have been friends a long
time how long how long have we we've
been over a decade now yeah and uh
probably 2010 George has his areas of
expertise outside of our work and and I
do as well well and what I love about
our relationship is is I'm into sports
and you are not is that fa that's a very
fair assessment and and so that's great
and and but yet we enjoy talking about
sports because I enjoy learning from you
you're a great teacher so I thought how
about we combine my love of football and
your love of budgeting and numbers and
and and so I thought this is an
interesting article are you ready for
this okay so in my hands here uh we
we've got an A A Blog here and uh this
is a survey and they they written
they've written about the story the
survey and here's the headline what's
the score on consumer spending this
football season oo now see I knew that's
a football headline that would get you
excited so uh here we go experion did a
survey asking football fans now this
would be College George college football
are you familiar with this well they not
count the NFL uh you didn't let me
finish oh sorry uh you got answer the
questions as they come to you okay okay
are you familiar with that colleges and
universities have football teams I know
about the SEC okay great uh big business
yeah big money and then of course the
NFL all right so they Sur money I
imagine oh yeah they surveyed uh
football fans college and NFL fans and
they asked them what they spend for the
pregame experience that would be
tailgating are you familiar with this
concept yeah but the whole pregame thing
feels strange to me still well you got
to get there ahead of time you make a
whole day of it you do well you get
there early cuz you got to anyway and so
people hang out in the parking lot it's
the old idea of of dropping the tailgate
of a truck is where this this comes from
you sit on the tailgate or you you big
cooler and you got your 12 packs your
six packs your your snacks and it's
gotten out of hand I mean they have t
they got chair I mean there's Furniture
C it's a culture now people bringing RVs
giant TVs watching the pregame postgame
in the parking lot it's amazing I I
could enjoy that part would you take me
what I'm going to take you to a football
game in tailgate it'll be great content
for YouTube we can film it all YouTube
we'll strap on some GoPros so here's
what they found how much are you
spending pregame during a football game
uh and and that will include everything
from chips and salsa on the couch at
their home to tickets on the 50 yard
line so this is any money you spend on
football all right okay and here's what
they found that fans expect to spend an
average of
$743 on football throughout the whole
2023 season about one and five say they
anticipate they'll overspend on football
this year 12% saying they're likely to
go into hold it George debt to go into
debt presumably on the credit card to
finance their football fandom to go to
the game that's the big thing or have a
party at the house maybe they're
spending money uh extra grocery money
they can't afford to cook some wings
have a football party for hey you bring
the chips and dip I'll bring the buffalo
chicken dip you know all right now hold
on this is going to get you this is
going to give you
heartburn 20% of fed said they'd be
willing to take on $5,000 in debt to get
to see their team play in a championship
game so maybe the AFC or NFC Conference
Championship or the Super Bowl or a bowl
game what do you think about that well
it's confusing are they saying hey if my
I want to see my team win or they're
saying hey if your team makes it to the
championship I'm willing to take on five
grand in debt to go to that game yeah
that's insane cuz these are the same
people making fun of Taylor Swift fans
for spending two grand for Taylor Swift
tickets they have no right to do that
after spending five grand to see their
team win the championship let me throw
another one at you 33% of the fans
surveyed said they would eliminate their
outstanding debt in exchange for their
favorite NFL team not winning a
championship for another 20 years that's
a very confusing survey question it
really is you understand it so they
saying hey I would get rid of my debt in
exchange for my team not winning a
championship for 20 years yeah that
makes no sense they're saying they'd
rather like the pain of paying off debt
yeah they're like I would take that over
my team not winning for 20 years I feel
like based on the teams you enjoy Ken
you wouldn't have to even make that bet
oh wow yeah who are you rooting for well
you're a Georgia Bulldog guy right no
I'm a Michigan Wolverine fan first and
foremost oh well it's more for our
Tennessee fans and probably the Jets
fans out there yeah but you see what
they're going is it it's like that
you've nailed it they're they're
exchanging that love of the game is
driving terrible decisions yes that's
the point so here's what I wanted your
take on George financially the word fan
comes from fanatic yes you got that and
so people are making fanatical decisions
that are hurting them financially the
one that stuck out to me the most was
the $5,000 willing to go into debt to go
on a a trip and see your team play go to
Deb you bring how the mental gymnastics
they used to get there make sense to me
cuz they go Ken this could be the only
time they ever make it to the
championship so they start to play all
these scenarios in their head and they
go this is it I'm going to be able to
tell my kids I was at that game right
that's the narrative they're playing in
their head yeah now what did you think
of the
$743 I actually thought that was kind of
low these people aren't spending a ton
because $743 over a full season well for
two people going to a game that feels
like that's it you just blew that 750 if
you're going to game you're going to be
close if you talk about travel parking F
parking gas food the tickets could be
well over 250 no CL I have no scale for
what a game costs these days well you
know a cheap seat ticket could cost you
anywhere from 45 to 50 bucks cheap cheap
seat depending on where it is to the NFL
you're paying several hundred each for a
ticket can I be honest I've been to one
game I got the tiets for free it was a a
Titans Patriots game okay and you know
I'm from Boston and I own a Brady Jersey
because the team bought it for me for a
live event we did but you don't even
know his first name I Tom oh okay that's
a little bit more than I expected very
proud of you but they got spanked by the
Titans it was embarrassing I was pulling
my jacket over the Jersey but let me
tell you I was staring at the big screen
the whole time cuz I couldn't see from
these cheap seats what was going on on
the field and I went I would rather
watch this at home then just listen to
people screaming at me you have no
commentary you can listen to like you
can on TV and for that reason I'm out on
live football right now but I would go
with you could we do the face paint and
everything uh you are the only person
that I would paint my face for because
that would be funny you and I the world
take that Stacy Coleman yeah yeah I'm
the only person in the world he would do
that for right well first of all Stacy
wouldn't let me do it she'd be
embarrassed you on the other hand would
enjoy it because you'd make fun of me
for years well I great at the end of the
day I'm okay with people loving Sports I
have no nothing against that but going
de5 on your credit card it's not fandom
it's financially dumb and I stand by
that I think you're right and and at
some point you've got to go what is most
important so what's the okay so let's
just talk about some discipline here
what's the emotional and mental exercise
that someone who's trying to get out of
debt let's put them in baby step two I
mean they're supposed to be riceing and
beans in it right and they love their
team I mean even if they have a party
let's say that they just started the
debt-free journey they should not be
throwing the party they should be
attending the friends party who paid for
the cable and they can bring a they can
bring a side okay that's it it's that
simple but don't put that on yourself
and don't sign up for the NFL package or
whatever you know paying an extra 50
bucks a month to access all
this I'm just saying if you're in debt
you need to have priorities go down to
your local sports bar and go watch the
game with some buddies and get yourself
a nice water and enjoy the game okay I
like that I was also going to suggest
that with Dave Ramsey's you know decades
long advice of rice and Bean beans beans
and rice you can make a nice bean dip
and be a hero a seven layer bean dip
goes a long way so a lot of beans out
there and you put some beans together
bean dip I'm sure there's got to you
that's what you need to do you need to
do a YouTube video on how to make a
budget for the friendly bean dip to take
to the big game oh if America would
watch it I would make it I'm here to
troll the sports fans and we enjoy it
guarantee you that that hits big on your
YouTube channel here's the thing just
budget budget for it put a line item if
you want to go to the game get the
Jersey throw the party that's fine but
don't go into debt for fandom I agree
and by the way if you'd like to bring
some bean dip to the Ramsay office next
time George and ion together we will
sample it live I will not be eating bean
dip from strangers I trust the people
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian healthare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all all 50 states so see
if chm could be right for your family
check out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel this
hour we're here for you to talk to you
about your money how about your work
your
income are you feeling like you got a
lid on you well I can help you there and
George is here to answer your money
questions 8825 5225 is the number that's
5225 Cara joins us now in Providence
Rhode Island Cara how can we
help hey Ken and uh George how are you
today good what's going on um to just a
quick comment about your NFL thing and
then I get to my quick question oh I
love it um I just have to laugh because
first off my husband and I were looking
uh because of just how crazy streaming
is right now um to be able to stream
football we were looking at some of our
options and it's like up or it's over
$900 a year you know just depending on
what service you're using which is just
absolutely insane 75 bucks a month no
thank you yes yes and then my other
thing was George you are aware that
hummus is a bean dip right that's true
thank you cara the food of my people
well I'll make some of Mama camels
hummus recipe Ken yeah we did a hummus
we did a hummus uh feature one time on
the show together George and I love
hummus love talking hummus yeah by the
way James Childs our fearless leader
does as well so um thank you for
pointing that out love the commentary
and so you show up at the football party
with some hummus yeah it's a great
suggestion by you the listeners so um
okay how can we help okay so I'm on baby
step two and um we we've got kind of a
big mountain to roll down which is fine
we're working on it but um I have this
little brokerage account and this little
stock Employee Stock purchase account
that I have stopped contributing to
because I of you know where I'm at in
the baby steps I guess my question is
though because it's a few thousand
dollars um I could cash those two things
out and just knock out about three small
debts Allin one shot I'm just it would
be the short-term capital gains taxes
that I'm worried about um it's again
it's not a huge amount of money so like
the taxes wouldn't be insane I guess my
question is because it's so small should
I just leave it and still keep fing away
or I kind of really want that momentum
I think the momentum beats out the tax
hit which I assume is going to be a few
hundred bucks at the end of the day yeah
it's not a huge amount of money but it
like I said it would just knock out
three debts in one shot so that's
amazing so what's sitting in these uh in
the ESP and the brokerage
account there's like I want to say like
1,500 of my the company that I work for
in the ESP obviously and then it's like
I don't know like 2500 in The Brokerage
um so yeah that was just kind of so four
grand we can throw at debt and you'll
knock out three of them which frees up
those payments yeah yeah that was my
question do it 100% And I I'll tell you
this Cara someone who did that at the
tail end of my debt free Journey getting
rid of $40,000 in student loans and
credit cards I had worked at the Apple
Store and I was just an 18-year-old and
they said hey we've got the stock thing
and I was like okay whatever I didn't
know what I was doing and so it ended up
to be like s Grand or something sitting
in that account that helped you know
kind of Kickstart my adult journey and
get me through the baby steps and I
people go George I could have turned
into $50,000 if you had just left it and
I'm like yeah but I'm Deb free today
living my best life I'm not worried
about what could have been and so that's
what you have to worry about now is not
looking back in 5 years from now going
if I just kept those stocks it could
have been this much because guess what
you're going to be investing faster if
you're out of debt sooner right yes and
investing
more yeah so yeah that that makes that
makes sense I appreciate it I guess this
kind of like a mindset split 100% it's
more mindset than the numbers cuz that
few hundred bucks you'll pay on that is
going to be nothing compared to the
feeling of debt Freedom love that
awesome and car I'll a football party
with my Brady Jersey on oh there it is
she Hey listen do you all right gotta
ask you cara do you keep bich or do you
fire him you're on the spot uh I mean
honestly I I'm gonna keep him oh there
it is folks all right little bit of
footb you can look him up later I know
he's the grumpy guy he's always looking
so grumpy you know cuz he realizes he
cut his sleeves off his sweatshirt and
he regrets that I think every game he's
like a that was a bad move shouldn't
have done that yeah fantastic thanks for
the call Cara all right let's go to
Albuquerque New Mexico John joins us
there John how can we help hi guys how
you doing this morning uh we're having a
blast what's going on okay so um I have
a question uh I was wondering if it
would be a good idea to do a 401k loan
to pay off a lot of debt that I have in
collections why I ask is because um 18
months ago I was injured at work and my
company shut down 100- year-old Trucking
Company um and I have a new job but I
have to get my Q clearance for um secret
documents and
stuff um I'm wondering if that's going
to inhibit me from getting that job
having the dead in
collections do you have any evidence
that that would be the
case um nobody's told me that they said
oh as long as you show that you know
you're you're paying it you know I have
a plan um and I'm working on paying them
how much do you owe but what's in
collection I so I have about 7K total um
because when I was hurt I was only
making 2third of my income is which is
why I kind of got behind um I have 7,000
I was sued last month for 39 for for
3,400 and I'm paying off another
Judgment at the end of this month so
what is your income now um the new job
is going to be before I get my my
clearances 990,000 then I get an extra
20,000 after I get my clearance but are
you currently
working um yes I'm I'm working with them
I I'm going through the process now I
submitted all my documents hold on
you're saying you're already getting
paid by these people yes okay so but you
don't have the job yet yeah yeah I I
have the job I'm going to work I'm
training it's going to be training for
okay confused cuz you said the new job
that you're hoping to get and you're
worried that you couldn't get it with
all this collection now you're saying
you're working for him so we're really
confused okay so I'm working for him
that the job is contingent with me
getting um my clearance that's why
everybody's uh at the new job is saying
oh don't worry about it you know if
you're here you know you're already in
the building on the payroll man I
wouldn't worry about it and if they ask
then say Hey listen here's where I'm at
let me update them I'm working on paying
this off here's what Happ happened be
honest tell them the story and let them
know it it's going to be cleared up real
soon so no to the 401K loan you don't
need to make tell George telling why
that's going to make life even worse
than getting rid of all this collected
debt well it's putting your future
behind and then they're still going to
see a 401k loan if they check your
credit report and so it's not you're
just moving debt from one place to
another and so I'd rather you just be
honest and upfront say hey look I'm I'm
working on settling these debts they
should be cleaned up the next few months
I mean you're making about six fig
how quickly could you pay all this off
making six figures few months between
all the debt we have I'm thinking what
the collections I should be able to pay
off in 6 months at least um our total
Deb weth thinking 18 to 24 at Max um so
let's prioritize the collections debt to
get that out of our life and then focus
on you know we'll be making minimum
payments on the rest of our Consumer
Debt until we're out of that then we'll
go hard doing the debt snowball but just
be honest and up front say Hey listen
less than six months this is cleaned up
here's what happened but again you're
already on payroll it's not like yeah
they like you they've given you some
evidence that they're not worried about
it and again you know listen it's not an
excuse but you know you went through a
tough
situation and and it's and and people
understand that by the way uh do you
mind there was a was it the uh was it
yellow truck is that that the company
you worked for yes that's amazing that's
a big story and that's why I asked him
100 plus year massive company that goes
out of business yeah with
our stuff was going on the same time as
UPS was and we were just there in the
background the way talked much about it
till yeah it was a national story when
it hit because it's such an old company
been around a long time and this new
economy and the way things are going and
so John that we're talking to here you
know he he got caught up in that and
that's that's tough stuff and so I I
think the moral of the story here is for
anybody that's listening or watching
George that may have a similar situation
be honest you know I if people want you
and they go you're a good truck driver
you got a nice track record here uh look
be honest don't but don't compound the
mistake trying to clean up something
need to be covered up that's the
takeaway here yeah I like it wow good
stuff bounc back that's amazing glad six
figures now yeah by the way anybody
looking to get a really good paying job
the trucking industry needs reliable
drivers it's a massive opportunity and
you can listen to Great podcasts like
the ramsy show maybe even George and
Rachel's wildly
successful just a route of a show now
you're just ribbing me Ken huh you're
just ribbing us no it's a great show
tell them what the name is smart money
happy there it is check it out while
you're in the cab this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
a debt settlement company and they're
not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramy show where we
help you win with your money and in your
work and in your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel this
hour 88255 225 hey if you are new to the
show welcome and you hear some jargon if
you will uh baby step numbers and
gazelle intensity and beans and rice you
go what is this language we've got a
great uh button for you called get
started if you're new to all this and it
only takes you a couple minutes click on
the get started button at ramsy
solutions.com quick little survey and it
just
catches you up to where you are in the
financial Journey the baby steps that we
teach and uh get you get you kind of
integrated quickly ramsy solutions.com
the website the mothership and click on
the get started button all right let's
get back to the phones Jennifer joins us
now in St Louis Missouri Jennifer how
can we help hey guys how are you doing
today we're doing great how are you I'm
great I'm Coen I finished Financial
Peace University back in 2015 excellent
I've had everything paid off since then
and recently I was hit by a drunk driver
and I'm in a situation of having to
purchase a car oh no are you okay
physically I am I am I'm good okay
financially I don't want to pay for the
new one right so what happened uh
insurance-wise
they obviously took all ownership uh my
car was paid out but I drove an old
beater with a heater it was old had a
lot of miles on it it still ran so I
didn't get a lot for it okay so what was
the check that wrote you 10,000 that's
that's something not bad I thought it
was going to be lower than that so do
you still have the 10,000 I do yeah okay
and what's your question today so my
question today is all these years I've
been saving for a home the only piece of
the process I don't have I have all this
saved up and now I feel like um I need
to take money out for a vehicle and I'm
trying to realign what is more important
especially looking at the economy the
market I'm scared to let go of that
money how much do you spend on a car
what's your income how much I be putting
about 100,000 amazing and that's just
you yeah I'm a single Source income Okay
cool so the parameters on anything with
motors in it is no more than 50% of your
income and that includes boats toys cars
everything in the house and so I'm not
saying go out and spend 50 Grand on a
car you definitely don't need that I
wouldn't suggest it um but I also don't
want you to get you know a $3,000 car if
you don't have to if you're not
struggling in debt trying to climb out
of this hole so do you have any debt
right now none I haven't had that since
2015 awesome and you have an emergency
fund uh yes a very healthy one great
what do we
talking 90 whoa and is that and that
doesn't include the money you save for
the house yes so how much did you save
for the
house well it's all in the same savings
oh so it's your total
that's my six months yeah and then I
have um been saving money for the house
on the side trying to get out of that
20% or put towards that 20% what are you
driving right
now a friend's old car that has a lot of
miles on it and might lose a wheel after
I turn the corner Sher you you you have
got to take care of you especially after
that accident you were in my goodness
get yourself a car what do you want can
we dream for a moment cuz you got the
money you you you earn it you save it
and you hold on to it you don't want to
let it go yeah but uh if you don't
figure this out soon um you're going to
be driving around a corner and all the
wheels are going to come off like some
type of cartoon so that's not I want you
calling back in with that call so what
kind of car do you
want um you know I was looking at a
Blazer or something on the market I I go
back and forth on new
used what is the better option so
expensive let's go you unless you've got
a net worth of a million bucks or more I
don't want you taking that hit on
depreciation before you can stach so but
here's the thing people go well George
the used car prices there is just as
much as new not true no no I'm sorry but
it's but it's tight it's a it's a tight
margin there yeah well you're also
looking at almost new cars at that point
yeah but what have you been looking at
these Blazers what are they what are
they going for something that's two
three four years old what is it going
for um about two or three probably about
3540 okay well what about a five to
seven year old
version I haven't looked there yet
that's where I would go that's where I
would go I drive a 10-year-old vehicle
yeah and I'm doing fine financially but
I see no need to just upgrade to the
latest and greatest for fun I do that
with iPhones that's where I do it Ken
not with cars okay I like that well a
lot less much smaller price point so
Jennifer here's what I would do I would
split your savings I don't like having a
giant pile that's your emergency fund
plus Car Plus down payment because then
it hurts when you parse it out and you
put 35 in a car fund and you put 40 in
the emergency fund and you put 50 in the
house down payment fund now we have
names for these things so then you don't
feel bad spending from the car fund okay
makes sense but I would take your time
with it we've got a great car buying
guide at ramsy solutions.com that you
can access and it's going to walk you
through all the steps I want you to do
this a smart way don't be desperate I
know it's a crazy time in the car market
do a test drive get the inspection done
go to a reputable independent used car
dealership do your research ahead of
time you better know more about that car
than the dealer does yeah but can I just
say I think you do and Jennifer listen I
I just bought a car for my son I got
another kid coming up in April I'm
looking at used cars all the time
because I'm in that market and I will
tell you that if you do some search in
your
area search between 15 and 20 grand
smaller midsize SUVs don't limit
yourself to a Blazer I think you're
going to be pleasantly surprised uh what
you might be able to find um I just got
a Ford Explorer for my son uh paid
12,000 uh and it was a 2010 is a 2010
and Immaculate condition 100,000 miles
bought it from an older couple fabulous
car for a for a 17-year-old boy you know
what I'm saying yeah if I pulled that
car up to your house right now now you'd
go bananas it's that nice it's in great
shape inside and out so I'm just giving
you and I'm telling you shch between 15
and 20 just you can see what your
options are because that's a number that
George I think I like that number based
on your recommendation it's nowhere near
the 50% Mark yeah I think that's going
to make you feel some guilt and then
you're going to see that card depreciate
and because you're a numbers person it's
going to hurt even more and so that's
why I tell you find the happy middle
ground it doesn't need to be the worst
Trailblazer you've ever seen in your
life it doesn't need to be the brand new
one and don't let them talk you into
that when you're on the lot which is why
I don't want you to start at the brand
new car dealership start your search
online overing yeah yeah exactly it's
overwhelming so start online and start
to get a feel for hey here's what I can
get in this range do I want to up it do
I want to bring it down and then do the
test drive get the inspection write a
personal check or cashier's check and be
done with it don't let them Swindle you
into warranties and all kinds of random
fees no yeah I've never purchased this
I've always bought new used and what I
bought new Ed then is now 20 ,000 more
today so it's just crazy how much that's
what hurts even more for those that are
car shopping these days and I'll I'll
say this to Jennifer to our entire
audience George uh I'm a fan I always
look at like Facebook Marketplace things
like that where I can talk to a real
person and I like to go look at the car
talk to them look him in the eye say hey
are you willing to let me take this to
my mechanic if they are now you know
you're in probably good shape and all
cash
is powerful and you never know who's
selling a car right now because they're
swimming in debt true so you walk up and
let's say somebody listed a car at 15
and let's say it's right at the blue BL
value maybe it's a a little high or
whatever go in and go look I'll give you
13 cash
today you never know what could happen
there George they want cash absolutely
and you show them the cash you know and
I just did a nice search on auto trader
here Ken for fun and I'm seeing plenty
of 2021 Trailblazers going for 20 to
$26,000 so perfectly in her price range
she's got the cash to do it beautiful
cars they look brand new so yeah it's an
option there it is you got option this
idea that well the brand new ones well
the brand new ones are 40 right and so
yeah you could find used ones that are
35 if they got a few miles on it but
there's other options out there don't
back yourself into a corner and make a
stupid decision cuz you wanted it for
your own ego that's what people do a lot
of the time that's right and every wants
to say they got the new car but they're
just literally mortgaging their life
away to drive a nice new car and then
they're underwater on it calling our
show yeah so don't do that be smart oh
it's crazy my gosh I'm going to have to
get some uh peps at AC on this cars
Sports buying cars for my kids has got
me stressed out but good hour George
want to thank James and the crew for
keeping us on the air we want to thank
you America this is your show this is
the ramsy
show
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the ramsy baby
steps go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button will
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramseys solutions.com and
click get
[Music]
started
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships the phone number to
jump in for your question is AAA
8825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman joined by my
esteemed colleague and dear friend
George camel with a k k m l if you're
keeping score at home uh you can follow
him on all the socials by uh punching in
those uh as well and at Ken Coleman
which is confusing because the k for Ken
C for Coleman don't get a twisted I see
a lot of alliteration there it's easy to
remember Ken Coleman and uh all of the
Barbie stuff has really changed my name
like kery and I largely flew under the
radar uh until the Barbie movie came out
and now everybody's got jokes and puns
have you seen it I haven't I think it's
time no my wife and daughter went to see
it as appropriate but uh I would lose my
man card and uh and so I I've choose to
keep my man cart I'm not going to go see
it love I'm I'm going to try to bring
the kenergy uh there it is so I am KU
see all these are just awful it just
hits different when you say it versus
Ryan Gosling I'm just saying I agree
I'll never be as cool as Ryan Gosling
but but I digress to the phones we go
thankfully Josh is on the line in Austin
Texas Josh how can we help yeah hey guys
uh thanks for taking my call um quick
question on my mortgage I got a 30-year
ARM mortgage and um it adjust every
eight eight years and I'm coming up on
the eight years and so the rate it never
goes below 4% and it never goes above
8% and um so I was just wondering Should
I refinance it or is that something that
just you know just kind of keep just
paying extra on it a month have you
looked into the terms of what it would
look like to
refinance so I was looking around like
kind of online and just looking I went
through Churchill and I I contacted them
and they really I told them I said you
know if it's not doesn't make sense to
refinance it I'm not going to and I kind
of just dropped the ball and really
never Fel followed up with them and that
was a while back when the rates were
still you know around five or six so I
think they're around like seven right
now to yeah they're gonna they're just
going to keep climbing as the morgage
interest rates keep climbing getting
closer to eight as we speak cuz the arms
are just transferring the risk of rising
interest rates to you yeah and the thing
is is the the the amortization charges
flips whenever the rate you know adjust
so I'm back at square one anyway anyways
I just didn't know I mean we're debt
free right now um we're in four five and
six I just didn't know if it' makees
sense to you know just keep we're making
an extra house payment every month as it
is yeah towards towards the mortgage I
would definitely look into refinancing
and just you can you can run the numbers
they can show you exactly when you would
kind of Roi on this H but right now
right that we just got the the latest
numbers 30 years are at 7.8 15 years are
at
7.03 um not true it's just it's jumped
over uh eight now I don't know what site
that is uh it's called Google Google
what do they know yeah who knows what
they are right now but if you can lock
in one below eight you're going to be
way better off I got you yeah that was
my main question and one other question
if you guys have time sure uh is it
BlueBell ice cream that you put in these
Root Beer Floats or is it a Ben and
Jerry it's it's I don't know what
George's answer is but for me it's
Bluebell every day of the week and twice
on Sunday you thank you you can come to
Texas any see that I got an invite to
Texas call me a bougie New Englander but
I'll take Ben and Jerry's over Bluebell
any day oh my gosh we got to change his
mind Ken I know that's he lost a lot of
votes as being a man of the people I'm
way ahead in that race right now I'm
sorry I listen if you can buy it by the
gallon the ice cream's not that great
that's all I'm saying no shade at Blue
Bell but if you can buy in a giant
bucket how good how high quality is this
ice cream there's a reason why it's in
the larger container we want more of it
that's where you missed this tell him
Josh quantity over quality for Ken all
right I'm going to stop you while you're
ahead George you're losing people by the
minute now Americans are now going how
can I trust Financial advice from a guy
who doesn't like BlueBell ice cream
George you got to read the room Jerry's
has more exciting flavors and I stand by
that although Blue Bell twostep you
can't beat it all right very good let's
go to who's joining us in Key West
Florida Natalie how can we help hi thank
you so much for taking my question um so
my question is I was in a car accident
last month and long story short my life
kind of Flash before my eyes and I'm
wondering if I should use the settlement
money as a buffer until I find something
that I truly love because I'm in a job
where um I just am not feeling
fulfilled how much much money did you
get from the settlement I got about
$22,000 um I had just paid off my car
and then the car AC happened um but I
did get about 22,000 and I I do have
some in savings as well do you have a
car now no is that a
problem um not I've been able to manage
without it what have you been doing for
transportation um I've been getting
rides and the next step for me I was
either thinking about getting a JY or
taking the bus all right what is your
income
now um I make about 990,000 a year wow
what do you do um I work in Hospitality
accounting okay so what is it that you
would like to do because somebody who
has thought long and hard about the
question you just asked can I use my
settlement money until I find a job that
I enjoy I think you've probably thought
about what it is you'd like to do so
what is it that you would like to do so
I have been playing around with the
ideas of traveling and I also have um
some side hustles that I've been doing
um I like to Thrift and to resell and
also like Amazon influencer with user
generated
content um I just feel like if I didn't
have this job I might be able to focus
on that but I think why can't you do it
on the side for now and get that off the
ground and see if it's lucrative yeah um
I'm doing it now on the side but I'm
also in grad school so I haven't been uh
able to focus on it as
now we're getting somewhere why grad
school and how deep are you into it give
me the quick answer so I um have two
more semesters and I'm taking classes so
I can uh eventually get my CPA I'm so
confused but you don't want to be a
CPA I do but I don't want to work in
Hospitality accounting I probably all
right so why don't okay so here's the
quick answer because we got about a
minute okay here's here's what I would
do if I were you I would stay in the
current accounting job cuz you're making
really nice money I would use the
settlement money that you got to
actually pay cash for a good car so that
you have some freedom and options okay
and you're making really good money and
so that I would be looking for a path to
becoming a CPA in a different industry
I.E not the hospitality industry that's
what you want to do and you can keep
Doling around on the side with these
side hustles and if they take off great
but what you really want to be is CPA so
uh I would not use the settlement money
to live off of while you try to find a
different job that is not wise
settlement money replace the car stay in
the $90,000 accounting job finish the
grad degree work the connections I'm
going to give you my bestselling book
The Proximity principle use it to become
a CPA in a different industry and now
you have the best of all worlds thank
you for the call this is the Ramsey Show
very k sightful
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsay show where we
talk with you about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships I'm Ken Coleman
George camel joins me the phone number
for you to jump in Isle
8825 5225 that's
8825 5225 it's time for our question of
the day and is sponsored by neighborly
your hub for Home Services it's time to
handle those projects before winter
makes you push pause and neighborly has
top quality home service providers like
Mr Rutter glass doctor and more so find
the and book the local help that you
need by downloading the neighborly app
today today's question comes from Rees
in Kentucky buckle up Ken all right
thank you all so much finding your
channel on YouTube Last December has
been lifechanging for me getting out of
debt I've been struggling with deciding
to change jobs and the question I've
been struggling with is how do I move
forward in expanding my skills and my
career without feeling guilty about
leaving my current job they go on to say
I've been aware for some time that I'm
underpaid however I know I'm valued
considering the added responsibilities
that have been given to me since I
started here the company I work for does
not offer health insurance or a 401k
I've developed a great working
relationship with my supervisor who has
been a great mentor to me the Rel ship
has me feeling guilty about even
applying for other jobs this is
challenging as I try to get through baby
step 2 as I know I want to increase my
primary income I found another company
offering better pay incentives benefits
and 401K options but I'm afraid leaving
my current job Bo while we're also under
staffed yep will sour the relationships
I've built yeah so Reese is one of the
nicest people on the planet Sal to the
Earth and because of that this
guilt uh is is coming over you and and
actually uh I've coached so many people
on this issue that I will start with
saying Rees and anybody that's feeling
this the guilt is actually an excuse
that you're making because you're afraid
of moving on and you're the the change
that you know all any change is is is
fraught with fear because it's it
involves some
unknowns and so guilt comes in as a well
I I will be a jerk if I leave this nice
boss that I have now and uh the bottom
line is is that you're not doing
anything wrong legally you're not doing
anything wrong ethically so guilt
doesn't need to come into the equation
so no guilt um you can be grateful and
focus on gratitude not guilt grateful
for the opportunity that you had
grateful for the opportunity that you're
getting to make more money and get out
of the baby steps faster and move
forward and you cannot control what
people will say about you when you leave
anyway so don't worry about it be classy
leave the way you would want someone to
leave you in the same situation and move
forward so take the job stop thinking
about it I'll add this that reminds me
of a quote from a
psychologist Dr Gabor mate I believe
that's how you say it could also be from
Berne Brown according to deloney he's
heard it there too okay choose guilt
over resentment every time and someone
like Rees cuz I I'm this kind of
personality of the kind of the helper I
feel people please her right that's who
Reese is she's going to get resentful
over time she's now feeling stuck going
I should have left 5 years ago but here
I am still stuck today still underpaid
no benefits I'd rather her feel guilty
than resentful I agree uh and Ken
Coleman me once said I'd rather
disappoint someone than resent them
that's my version see how I stole that
like an artist it's more conversational
so a little uh extra bonus Point that's
how you take someone else's quote and
make it your own and you didn't
plagiarize a little extra bonus content
there uh but you know a lot of people
feel that because they don't want to
disappoint someone when you leave and
that's just part of it you know it's
like a breakup when you leave an
employer especially when you love he's
very relational you can tell that Reese
is very relational and I get that so
there you go appreciate the question
back to the phones we gople 8825
5225 Michael is on the line in Dover
Delaware Michael how can we help hi Ken
jge thank you guys so much for taking my
call you bet what's up so quick question
um I've been heavily um I'm starting
basically I hang on let me read this
I've been investing heavily and I'm
about to sell my car to get a reliable 5
to $10,000 beater in order to get out of
debt uh
my uh I'm very grateful to have this
opportunity but I'm in sales and I'm
moving to a new store in the company
with now about a year of experience uh
where I have the potential to make
anywhere from 150 to
250k um with obviously a ton of
potential to move beyond that with
promotions my question is I have a very
well connected family friend over in
London and he actually gave me an
opportunity to move into real estate
over there uh I don't want to regret not
making the move um just to kind of
expand my horizons but on the other hand
obviously I have an amazing opportunity
where I'm at and I don't want to lose
opportunity cost if that makes any sense
so just call to see what your guys
thought so what is the job this this 150
to 250 what is this job what are you
doing yeah yeah so I'm currently in car
sales um I'm current well in the new
position I'll be making like 150 to 250
but I was making but is that car sales
just you're just moving within the
industry correct okay and so the same
dealership but same dealersh okay and do
you enjoy selling I do I do like it a
lot do you like selling cars more than
you would like Selling
Houses I guess that's a good question I
that's why I asked it that's why I'm on
the show today so what's pulling you
towards uh this buddy in
London uh more so than anything I just I
kind of want to be able to expand my
horizons if that makes any sense I don't
want to feel stuck in one place how old
are you Michael 19 19 and and is this
guy uh is he successful or did he just
get his real estate license in London
and he's like woohoo let's have an
adventure what's the story so um
actually I got connected through him
through a gentleman through through one
of the general managers within my car
dealership um which is also a very close
family friend and he's been doing it for
quite a while he's very successful in
what he's doing runs the whole thing um
he he's like
24 um and his yeah and so the 24
year-old is very successful been doing
it a long time he might be successful
but he's not been doing anything a long
time he's 24 so how here's what I'm
trying to get to and I'm literally I'm
old enough to be your dad it pains me to
say that I'm really trying to play your
dad right now uh I like the idea at 19
of taking a shot to go to London and
work I like it on the surface as I think
if you're going to do that I think it's
great to see the world I think while
you're young yeah especially while
you're young you can come back and sell
cars for this same Automotive Group it
feels like when you're done because it's
all close family friends I love your
family I'd like to be a part of your
family sounds like being a part of your
family is very
advantageous I'm very blessed to being a
family I'm for sure I could tell so on
that I go all right I got two wins here
I got two check marks for yes one you're
19 you got an opportunity to go see the
world and work two you got a great gig
that's connected to family
relationships which connected you to
this guy in London so it feels like you
could come back at any time the only
thing I don't understand is do you know
that you know that you're going to be
able to come in there and sell some
houses if you do what this guy tells you
what kind of money is he projecting that
you will make and how
long yeah that's honestly a good
question and um I I my assumption he
told me close to around 200 starting out
so starting out you know you got to sell
a house right in order to make money
right for sure well so it's supposedly
it's some sort of uh closing gig so okay
so you need more details there's a lot
of assumptions and supposedly and I want
firm numbers and facts I'm not flying
across the pond on a whim even at 19 so
get some details on on this you really
want me what's the training look like
what do you estimate if I bust my butt
do what you tell me to do how long would
it take me to to sell a house I think if
I think if you got a good upside here
and I'd get the family friend's opinion
that connected to this young guy let's
get some more facts and then if it feels
right and it's not a big risk other than
hey I don't make any money I come back
to my job and I say go for it George
what do you think yeah I mean the car
sales will always be there but this
adventure at 19 I think he's going to
miss out and go man what would that been
like that would been cool I love I love
our good friends over in London I love
high tea it's about going maybe I'll see
if James can bring us in a little high
te setup for our next segment we'll see
I don't have my hopes very high no this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks Dr John deloney here with
with some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with a daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's 3 months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 990
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
the Ramsey Show continues I'm Ken
Coleman George camell is with me the
phone number for you is8 825 5225
8825 5225 let's go to Dale now who joins
us in San Antonio Texas Dale how can we
help
yes I had a question for you guys in
regards to Titan um I'm an owner
operator uh in the oil
field and um I don't know if you guys
you guys probably remember the oil you
know all the oil prices pank a while
back and you know we've been uh you know
basically got behind on all of our bills
including our mortgage um and uh just a
month ago um our truck actually caught
fire and the insurance company is's not
going to cover it so now we're yeah so
now we're uh we're basically working as
uh you know contract driver only making
like 30% of the pay so and then we also
found out that there's a chance that my
wife might be you know losing her job
here
soon and uh because she's a a you know
Works off of a con like a contract
temporary type job but um basically we
were trying to figure out like what are
we supposed to do when it comes to T in
if there may not be any money coming in
that week or you know not enough to be
able to cover the bill since you we're
behind on pretty much
everything I'm so sorry to hear about
all that Dale you guys are going through
it man do you before we get into that do
you guys have a plan are you actively
looking for a replacement job for her if
that shoe falls if you will and then
what are your what's your opt what are
your
options well I'm uh my wife is is
currently looking you know it's not very
easy to to find because um she working
remotely is the best option for her um
but uh she is looking at at other
options even if it includes you know
working at nighttime okay um but our our
kids go to a school that's like 30
minutes from us because we we're kind of
like outside of the city a little
ways and then um for myself basically I
I actually got a job driving uh driving
for the owner of the company I was
contracted with and so you know we're
we're the industry is starting to catch
back up and starting to get busy again
it's just you know taking taking the pay
cut is is kind of a huge thing but you
know with with really not having any
savings at the moment um you know it's
going to be a while before I can save up
enough to be able to buy another
truck okay even if you guys have debt
right
now yeah we do okay so you guys are
really at Ground Zero and baby step one
here yeah and we we've actually been at
baby St one for a little while we've
been trying to tackle things but you
know it's it's been kind of hard well I
think number one uh Ken can help you on
the career side we need to find
something stable because your wife is
wanting to work remote but these are
temporary contracts so I'd rather her
working something that's for a longer
period of time time that's more stable
and for you to potentially switch Fields
I mean if it's looking like this is not
going to bounce back quickly do you need
to switch Fields temporarily in order to
bring in
income s and on the tithing side you
know tithing comes from the first fruits
and so if the Harvest is light the tithe
is going to be light so I wouldn't
stress about what happens if there's no
income just figure out hey what was the
paycheck this month all right we're
going to give a little bit of that and
we're going to give a little until we
can go back to giving a lot but it's
it's a really a matter of the heart I
wouldn't stress about it during this
time as you guys are trying to get back
on your
feet now do you have other ideas as to
are you just trying to tread water right
now uh with this current driving job
with the boss of the company where
you're contracted or you just trying to
tread water until the the oil industry
opens back up or is there other driving
jobs or anything else quite frankly even
in a trade where you can get your income
back up to where you
were well I don't I don't think I there
may be a possibility somewhere but you
know going from an owner operator to a
contract driver is just it's just a huge
pay sure pay decrease matter what right
and the industry itself is starting to
rebound and so I we have tons of work in
the pipeline so I don't see it being a
problem is it's going to be a while
before I can actually get back into my
own truck how
long uh I don't know it depends on how
how busy things are and you know also in
regards to like trying to catch up on
our our debts because that has or catch
up on our bills right but here here's
what the reason I'm asking you why it's
because we need a plan here and so if on
one hand you're telling me the industry
is coming back and the pipeline is full
to where you could be owner operator and
get your income back up if I'm
understanding you right that's what you
you just
said so what is your best guess as to
when the pipeline begins to uh move
again and you're back at it again
because the income is there so that you
can pay the debt off because right now
you're not making it up so we it's
either or we've got to get busy with two
or three or four jobs right now or we
are treading water until so I I want to
know best guess when can you be making
the money again as the owner oper
opor if I buy the cheapest truck I can
get my hands on yeah it could be six
months maybe maybe three months but when
it comes to driving truck it's not like
you can take you know extra jobs and and
whatnot you have to run what you have
you can change companies and stuff like
that but you can't really like take on
extra jobs oh you're talking about in in
regards to your current
gig yeah as a truck driver yeah but but
my point is if I'm swimming in debt and
you are I'm not going to go well I can't
work extra jobs because of my current
job I could screw the current job and go
give me three or four you just go work
for a different company and drive their
truck as a
contractor uh not not while working you
know the company I'm with okay what I'm
saying is Dale listen I I'm going to be
tough here in the sense of you are
drowning you need income
and and we've got the program and George
can help you and we walk you through
getting rid of the debt but you need
income and so if it's six more months
before the pipeline gets back going to
where you can get back in the business
buy the cheapest truck possible and get
back on your feet pay the debt but but
it doesn't make sense to just tread
water when you're about to drown right
now because you go well I'm a contract
truck driver well go do something else
go do three or four or five things I
think it's that serious at least that's
how it sounds to me am I right or or am
I
wrong you are right it's just that in
the the the industry I'm at the only way
I can make more money is by owning my
own truck okay you're I'm gonna say it
again Dale get out of that industry
you're just driving for somebody else
right now get out of that industry go do
something
else you're limiting yourself what are
you making right
now yeah well I mean that's what doing
right now though I mean this is the best
thing that so what is your income right
now Dale financially with this part-time
contract
stuff but it's it's full-time but
it's uh 100 a year okay and you're
telling me 100 a year you can't pay off
some debt and get back to some
Foundation well we we can now the last
the last six months have been well below
that and I probably should have left a
long time ago to go do something else
for a while and I didn't I think there's
other issues here though if we're stuck
in baby step one which is $1,000 and
you're bringing in now $100,000 and
we're still stuck in this
phase right no and I understand that
it's just that we we started a little
late like we started this when
everything kind of
CH so we were you know we were doing
more than 100,000 before that this is
just you know we were doing probably I
think you and your need to sit down and
make a budget based off what's coming in
this month and go this is our plan we're
going to stick to it I'll gift you one
year of every dollar premium so that it
connects to your bank you can drag the
transactions in but you guys need to
agree on this plan cuz right now it
feels like you've been floating through
life life has happened to you but you've
also just kind of let life happen to you
and it's time to get in the driver's
seat pun intended Dale and just get busy
we are in an economy right now at 3.8%
unemployment rate there are jobs all
over the place get after it for heaven's
sakes go work five jobs for 6 months or
whatever it takes to get some margin
don't limit yourself this is the ramsy
[Music]
show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me this hour
and we are thrilled that you are with us
talking about your life specifically
your money your work and your
relationships and uh our very this is
very exciting we have a uh first time
event that is happening in just weeks
it's our first ever money and marriage
getaway now we've done the money and
marriage events before Georgia you know
I think you and I have both hosted a
version of those at some point they're
fun uh but this is a getaway October 19
through 21 right here on our campus you
and your spouse are going to be equipped
with tools to cast vision for your
family set goals and create a life you
both love at this getaway you're going
to have undistracted time to disconnect
from life and reconnect with your spouse
Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney will be your
guides as they discuss money
communication boundaries and intimacy
and and uh you're you're going to be on
this as well speak budgeting yeah okay
so that's one more reason one more
reason and Jade warshaw it's mentioned
Jade as well uh tickets cost $799 for
this multi-day event if you're out of
debt you've got room in the budget so
yeah $799 for a couple incidentally it's
very uh near the number of $735 at NFL
and college football fans said they
might spend over the course of a season
now one is an investment into the
national football League one is an
investment into your marriage Choose
Wisely guys I don't know I'm going to
say that investing in me being a fan is
for my mental health oh there we go I
wish John delone was here to
psychoanalyze that yeah I wouldn't care
what he had to say cuz I'm right when I
watch football with my family and
friends it is making me better I learned
what Friday Night Lights is thanks to
you Ken so I appreciate that exactly
exactly why are people going to see
lights what's so special about these
lights well it's what's happening Under
The Lights George uh so if you would
like like to come to Nashville for our
money and marriage getaway don't forget
the dates October 19th through 21 still
a few tickets left Rams solutions.com
events Ramy solutions.com events now
George uh you and I we sit next to each
other uh not just when we host a show
but but but uh during the day that's
called a double blessing it's a double
blessing George and I actually like each
other but we sit three feet away when we
are actually in the office and we talk
from time to time about your proclivity
you like that word that's a big one it
is people look it up I'm try toate
America yeah uh you like to get into the
comments whether it be the YouTubes yeah
the Instagrams the Facebooks the Tik
toks you're in the comments nothing
makes you feel older than adding an S to
everything that doesn't need one which
is why I do it do you also say Walmarts
or Kroger's I will start you that guy
I'm going to start saying that uh that's
my favorite I'm going to tell Stacy on
the way home going to the Kroger well I
feel as young as ever thanks to you k
that's my goal but you've got so you've
got an Instagram comment that I want to
get this was from you from my YouTube
channel oh from I apologize andas need
to read my notes better so on the George
Campell YouTube channel at the end of
the videos I'll say hey leave a comment
with XYZ and so on this particular video
it was millionaire reacts to what I
spend in a week I said hey let me know
in the comments your dumbest money
mistakes be vulnerable we'd love to hear
it okay and so uh Randomness 5074
username said that's the username yeah
here it is on the screen I don't want to
slide by that too Qui you know what ATM
means Ken do you know what that means as
an acronym uh automatic teller machine
no at the
moment Oh I thought you were really at
the moment yep so he says see I don't
like all this it makes me feel so old I
don't know what any of that means you'll
understand the rest he said I think that
WTF means why the face why the frown
there we go is that from Modern Family
it is that's a good reference so he said
ATM at the moment my dumbest purchase
was 4 100 shares of rivan stock at $65
oo now was rivan this new SUV I see
about electric truck company very cool
cars uh here's the thing Ken I then
Googled well I'm curious what's the
rivian share now cuz clearly he's upset
that he shares at 65 yes which by the
way if you're doing the math at home
comes out to $26,000 this oh boy this
young person spent what's the stock
price at now it's now at
$18 which means uh 400 * 18 k
7200 do we know why uh well I don't
think rivan has been doing great they've
been taking some losses which has hurt
their share price if you look at the
fiveyear uh track here it's not been
going well but it was a great reminder
for those of you especially young people
who go you know what I like Dave's
advice is fine with the 401ks and IAS
mutual funds boring I'm going to get
into single stocks I'm going to put all
my money on this one company to do well
over the foreseeable future
and I looked at when the price was at 65
it was back around January 2022 okay and
so we're talking uh you know almost
almost coming up on two years and this
bet did not pay off and I'm guessing
that's when the company came out like
they probably that was their debut it's
been going downhill for a while
basically he bought it on the down slope
and it just kept going down oh boy oh
boy so that is your he lost uh what 18
Grand so far 19 Grand on this deal wow
so there's your lesson for those of you
out there dabbling and single stocks I
don't own a single stock I have mutual
funds inside of my 401k and Ira that are
giant groups of stocks and so that is
the way to diversify K so you don't get
burned on something like this yeah and
so I want to stay here because this is
we have a lot of people that are new to
the program coming in and so I do want
to park here so for the person going
okay I hear but that was that stock they
they could have done their homework they
should have we all the
objections if you're going to play that
single stock and win you have got to be
monitoring that all the time oh it's
obsessive it's the same what would that
have to look like which I want to add to
that just is Not Practical to play the
single stock game because you have got
to be a paying attention all the time
almost a day trader if you will yeah
which those folks lose a whole lot of
money and anyone trying to get you into
day trading is about to make money off
of you and you're about to lose your
butt and so that's what we've seen time
and time again there's very few that get
into single stocks and go can I I did
GameStop and I I'm a millionaire now
overnight you get the occasional call
like that but most of them are hey I was
day trading I got into single stocks I
got into sports betting whatever it may
be and I've lost my butt and I'm in debt
cuz now the scary part is people are
going into debt to to gamble there's a
reason why there are stock professionals
and financial experts and there's a
reason why mutual funds have such a
great track record over the history with
all these stocks coming together because
you've got
the reams of paper George explain that
word in a long time re of paper well I'm
bringing them all out today apparently
but I mean the amount of research that
that I want people to understand why we
go with mutual funds because of the
research involved the expertise it's why
it's so safe and as a result over a long
term you're going to win yes these are
you know what we call actively managed
funds and so there's someone who's
actively choosing the funds the stocks
that go into these mutual funds and they
have done so much more re that's all
they do they live and breathe what's
going on in the news what companies are
up and coming what the changes they're
making are how that's going to affect
share prices and the best news is I
don't look at my 401k every day I look
at it like twice a year yeah I can't
access it anyways so I'm just going oh
cool good to know versus single stocks
or crypto you're looking at this stuff
all the time obsessing over it's
affecting your mental health your
relationships and of course your
finances right and and you could make
the case that single Stock Investing is
a bit of the lottery it it's a little
bit of uh roulette if we if we may it's
very volatile very risky and uh I don't
own any single stocks Dave Ramsey
doesn't own any single stocks and for
those that are wanting to do it there's
a time in place and that is when you're
already at baby step 7 you're maxing out
retirement and this is play money for
you and it's a very very very tiny
percentage of your world and you go all
right if I lose this money I set it on
fire I'm not going to miss it yeah so
that's the key with single stocks and
here's my hot take and I talk about this
a little tease my new book in January
but here's my hot take on single stocks
stingle socks are like betting all your
money on a single racehorse mutual funds
let you own the racetrack oh and that's
very good George Sports analogy for you
I'm very proud of you that's on paper as
in your new book yeah I worked hard on
that one did anybody give you that idea
no you did that on I was trying to think
of a good analogy and uh I must tell you
my brain wanders into sports I couldn't
be any proud
uh as an older brother I'm proud right
now that you have come up with a sports
analogy for your new book and it's a
great one by the way and that's why
we've talked about this don't get burned
on the single stock betting you might as
well go to the racetrack and go I'll
take horse number is go to the Kentucky
Derby with you Ken well uh I'm going to
wear a sear sucker suit I promise you
that with white bucks you were born sear
sucker I look great in sear sucker I'm
not going to lie to you but I digress
hey what a great hour more coming up
don't move he's George camell I'm Ken
Coleman James Charles and the crew are
the best in the business we do it all
for you America it's your show this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show hey George camel here if you love
the show and you want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the Ramy
way just go to ramsy solutions.com today
to sign up for the newsletter again
that's ramsy solutions.com to sign up
for our Weekly
[Music]
[Applause]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions this is the ramsy show
it's where we help you win in your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships the phone number to
jump in Isle 8 825 5225 that's 8 825
5225 I'm Ken Coleman he is George camel
looking Snappy today in his best denim
jacket so snappy snappy
you you haven't been called that in a
while have you well you use proclivity
uh esteemed colleague yeah I love the
$10 words we pick up when you're hosting
you I'm an old soul I read a lot and
these things just come out I'm not
trying to drop the 50 Cent words Snappy
certainly not well back in the during
the Great Depression when you should
have been alive those words were 50
cents now they're $10 with inflation Ken
that's good George I like that the Great
Depression wow with that we are going to
do a something special every once in a
while by the way before we get to this I
do want to say this uh we have a
fabulous and I do mean this I don't pick
this word lightly a fabulous group of
audience members in the lobby today
watching the show from all over the
world all over the world we've got some
Canadians that were out there we got
people from all across the country and
so I want to point out that you can come
watch the Ramsey Show live uh go to our
website and figure out the calendar and
and hopefully these folks aren't
disappointed that Dave's not here today
they get us uh two of the dve ETS Dave
but nonetheless they're a great group of
people and so we'd love to have you come
join us sometime free cookies and coffe
cookies coffees mug uh I'm having myself
a delicious uh green tea uh with a
little dollop of honey in it so that's
that's now you know Ken's drink order
guys there you go uh but but I bring
this up because every once in a while
we'll take a question from the lobby and
so we've got a question from Lynn and
it's work rated and so we want to
protect the old identity there and
sticky and so she's not on camera so
you're wondering why we aren't showing
Lynn because the the sensitivity of this
so we're going to help her out so Lynn
uh take it away what is your question
hey so I'm really grateful that it's you
and not Dave because you're the guy I
was hoping to talk to well how that that
can we clip that J I'm going frame it in
your house I think I'm going to tell my
mom this is exciting between yesterday
and today we got to see everybody except
for Dave so that's a little sad but I'm
here I'll tell him I'll tell him so um I
work in healthcare I've been working in
healthcare for about 13 years as a
clinician about 3 years ago I moved into
a hybrid role where I still get to be a
clinician and I also am in leadership um
and I've always really loved the place I
work with or work for the co-workers I
have and I really enjoy supervising the
about 20 employees that I have the issue
that I'm struggling with is there's
about 10 of us in the leadership team
and we're not always on the same page
and so it's gotten to be really
difficult to kind of do employee
relations and kind of work on the
culture because we're not always on the
same page and we don't agree on hand in
things the right way in the same way all
the time so my question is how do I know
when it's time to move on to a new place
and say like hey this is just not the
right place for me or when I really
should like buckle down and stay and
work on the culture from within since I
am a leader okay so
um is there a structure any structure
within the 10 liters or are you all
equal there is so there's like um six
managers and then there are four
supervisors and I'm one of the
supervisors okay and so like the four of
us are the same and the six of them are
the same and then it goes on and so this
breakdown of we can't get on the same
page correct has that been taken up or
is it primarily coming from the six
above you um we've gone up the ladder
with it it's that they really believe
and like everybody needs to be a unified
front we all have to have like the same
agreed response to everything so it's
hard because until you get agreement
from everybody we don't move forward
like a jury every day it yes yes it is
and so it becomes really hard cuz I
might want to handle an employee
relation thing a different way than
someone else but then I can't kind of
move forward and kind of manage my one
of my 20 employees the way they like I
might want to relate to them a little
different or whatever but if the group
doesn't agree then I don't get to do it
okay I will tell you I think that's
bananas okay I think it's bananas okay I
think it is absolutely yeah uh
mind-numbingly stupid okay and it's
created tremendous frustration for not
only you but I'm guessing for others for
others in the leadership team and I
think I see it um because I try to be
really engaged with my employees and I
can see that they're dissatisfied and I
think it would be an easy not an easy
change but there would be a way to
change it but I just don't know if I
have the clout from within that well it
doesn't sound like you do yeah probably
not and and so because you've so to
answer your question yes sir do you
leave or when do you know it's time to
leave I I think when you have taken it
up ladder and you said this feels
problematic this is grinding us to a
halt every time we have to just lead
we've got to go into a jury room and
come out all together right and this is
not a jury yeah this is not even
Congress this is a company and I think
because you've taken it up the ladder
and nothing's going to change I think
you have to ask yourself can you affect
culture that was a secondary part of
your question or do I try to change
culture within I don't know how you
change culture if you can't address your
team true so I would tell you that you
hit your lid it feels like to me on this
opportunity it's time to start looking
because I don't think it's going to
change right and and I think it's only a
matter of time if you were to just bite
the bullet and kind of deal with it
where you go from frustration to
resentment right that's what I'm afraid
of because I said I've always loved the
company I really love my co-workers I
really like the people I supervise I
don't want to become resentful but I
also as a leader like I have an
opportunity so I don't want to abandon
people but by the way by the way for
anybody listening and watching right now
what's maddening about this George to me
is we have people in a leadership
position it's a group of 10 leaders and
yet no one's actually leading there's a
lot of cooks in the kitchen by the way
folks you cannot lead from
consensus right I just want that to sit
for a second okay yeah you cannot lead
from consensus that that's not
leadership leadership by definition is
you're out front and you're going this
is where we're going this is why we're
going this is how we're going who's
coming with me it's the Jerry McGuire
moment and this is this is just bananas
to me so I I hate to tell you this cuz I
know you like the company right but you
won't like the company in too much
longer if you keep this up you can't do
this you're not allowed to lead right so
you are a leader in title only and sore
the rest of them so I I hate to deliver
the bad news George leadership we say
leadership is influ and right now you
don't have the power to have any
influence and that could mean a lack of
trust if you're continually running into
this and you're the soul person on the
other side of this going hey I don't
think we should do it this way that
might mean you disagree with the values
and principles and the way they run
things and that tells me it might be
your time because it's going to lead to
resentment and I'd rather you leave
before when Dave says when your when
your heart leaves your butt should
follow and if that's you it's time and
you seem very sharp I think you're going
to land in a great place yeah uh but you
could you know you could have one last
ditch effort say what you said to us to
your direct leader and say listen I'm
coming to you privately not with the
group I want to address this and if they
can't promise any change and they're not
making progress I'm starting to look
elsewhere you can take that shot I hate
to be a naysayer but it's not going to
happen that kind of group think is very
opposite of Common Sense and we live in
a day and age folks where leadership is
needed more than ever but we have so
many freaking leaders that are scared of
getting criticized so they don't lead
massive gap between common sense and
group think and this company is group
think cuz they're all scared to death to
lead oh it's exhausting
leave oh I need an aspirin this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman he is George camel and we are
here for you
88255 25 okay special request from the
audience I wrapped up the last segment
talking about you cannot lead from
consensus and and gentleman out there in
the lovely green shirt wants me to to
expound on that I will just give it 20
seconds what that means is is that you
don't lead based on everybody agreeing
with what you decide to do and so
consensus is like I got to get everybody
on board they got to agree with me
before I lead it doesn't work that way
you can cast Vision we say this is where
we got to go and if you're coming with
me great if you're not I get it move on
uh the the idea of leading from
consensus is what a politician does they
check the poll numbers to decide what
their next policy is and so that's what
I mean by that statement and I stand by
it uh you will drive yourself mad and
you'll never truly lead if you're always
looking for consensus so I hope that
makes sense to you sir I appreciate the
follow-up question all right triple 8825
5225 is the number to jump in let's go
to Memphis Tennessee where Megan joins
us Megan how can we
help hi guys thank you so much for
taking my call you
bet well I have a question regarding my
job um well and I'll start out first of
all my husband and I are on baby step
two okay um we I've done well I say we
but actually I did Financial Peace
University went through all of that um
and we are working on the baby steps but
my struggle right now is with my job I
am currently an educator I teach special
education and since 2020 of course I
know everybody's had issues with with
things happening but that was just
really a very very tough year for our
students for us with all of the virtual
learning and everything and I kept
saying oh after 2020 everything's going
to get better it's going to be great and
it really hasn't and so so I'm
struggling a lot with just physical
mental exhaustion completely overwhelmed
with the job just because it's not just
teaching that that we're doing we have
so many other things that are on our
plate it's getting harder every year um
and this is year 16 for me and I didn't
initially start out in education but um
kind of went a roundabout way to get
there and I love working with my special
needs students but I'm just tired yes
and I don't know what to do okay tell me
what you love most forget all the awful
stuff what do you love most about
working with your specialed
students I just love the the way that
they see things it's it's a totally
different perspective from what
typically yes you know you or I might
might see things or when they just have
that light bual moment that something
clicks and
I work with students that are getting
ready to age out of education and so we
work a lot on job skills and different
things like that and that that's what my
passion is to work with with those young
adults and get them life skills daily
living skills but I just don't know if
teaching is the the way I need to go
about that and on because it's well I
know it's not so let's go ahead and
based on what you said I agree
wholeheartedly with you you've got to
get out of the public school system okay
but you don't necessarily need to get
out of the same type of work so I would
classify your situation as someone who
is doing the right thing in the wrong
place does that make
sense yes it does okay so practically
speaking in Memphis Tennessee who and
you don't have to have the answer but
this is the question you have to answer
if you can't now who is helping those
those young people or should I say
adults who would have some of the same
needs have aged out of the public school
system but still need that help with job
placement life skills and such who's
helping those
people well I think that's a big
question in our area because we don't
have a lot of that and do you have some
of very difficult we have some yes and
and a lot of it is parent Le um we've
had parents that have um started doing
like recreational things with a group of
students in the area and that's that's
wonderful but are there organizations
whether it be nonprofit or governmental
that again are not in the public school
environment are there organizations
serving that group of
folks yes that's the answer we we start
what's
that I I said I feel that that's limited
but there are some organizations what do
you mean by limited just the the amount
of organizations that are doing it or
yes okay but have you have you looked at
those organizations to see if they're
hiring not yet that's where do when I
get off the phone with perfect no that's
great listen and that's what I'm trying
to do let's start there I don't think
you need to limit yourself there but
let's start there let's kick the tires
what are you making right now as a
teacher about 70,000 okay so you I'll be
honest with you it it might be difficult
to find a job making 70,000 are you in a
double income family do you need to make
70,000
um probably to to keep that that
snowball going that would be best now an
educator right so here's where I want to
Pivot we start with kicking the tires in
the space that you're in but then let's
look let's just pull back and the reason
that I asked you the question Megan what
do you love most about working with
those students in the special Edge
system is I wanted you to hear yourself
say
this is the kind of work that lights me
up and there's a level of
instruction doesn't mean you have to
stay in a classro environment in the
public school system but is there a
level of instruction uh HR training uh
working on working and instructing
people within the trades or maybe
working for you know you start to go
where can I instruct people who need
that
extra hand up and maybe they don't have
to be in special need situations but
maybe it's lower income people who are
getting trained in a certain area by
government agency or whatever you start
to just look everywhere you can in
Memphis to go where can I serve
people who need that extra help need
that dedication of a of a teacher the
heart of an instructor because I think
you love instructing people uh mentoring
cheering people on do I have that
right you do yes all right then so where
can we make 70,000
or more doing that that's the question
you have to answer and so you started
the phone call and George would get this
a lot you start the phone call Megan
where it feels very intimidating this is
a mountain I don't know how to climb and
I hope that I've been able to bring this
down on the street level and go all
right I can look for that and I think
you need to find instruction and
encouragement and guiding and guidance
in that job and I think she'll be happy
what do you think oh yeah yeah and I
love it and as you were talking about
that I thought you know what some of the
greatest entrepreneurs saw a problem
without a solution and they just created
it so maybe one day Megan starts her own
organization I agree in Memphis that
provides this and right now the first
step is let me see how other
organizations do it let me make money
let me get out of this debt use that as
fuel for your debt snowball to go one
day I want to be debt free so that I can
go start that thing and and Megan uh I
want to add to what George said he just
said something and that was really
insightful you know maybe you just go
get a really good $70,000 job and it's
not it's not the dream job it's not like
super passion and purpose and I'm the
guy that teaches do work that's
purposeful but maybe you go get a really
good paying job that gets us through
baby step two and then baby step three
Megan and then you're working on the
side maybe you're volunteering for this
group of folks so that you're making
progress on baby step two but your
heart's still very much alive does that
make
sense yes it does and George thank you
so much for saying that because I've
actually that kind of confirm my
thoughts about something possibly in
retirement that I actually start my own
organization that has the different
areas so thank you for saying that
you're so welcome well I just said what
I think was already in your heart and uh
we need people like you Megan in your
community that's right so thank you for
what you do and yeah Megan I I to close
this segment out uh Megan's right I I I
don't know if if you've ever volunteered
or spent time around some of the folks
she's talking about but they have an
unbelievable Joy and an unbelievable
innocence that I think we all in this
day and age could probably use 100% so
love Megan and the folks at work with
our um I don't like the whole idea of
challenged and all that I just think
they're special they're unique they're
different they got a whole lot to offer
this world lot to contribute and I love
that Megan and the folks that work with
that group of people do they are a
lighthouse to all of us in some dark
days this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
a
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me and we are
here for youle 8825 5225 taking your
money questions your work questions uh
we'll take some relationship questions I
mean hey why not you've been married for
how many years uh 25 add my five 30
years 30 years 30 years of doing it
wrong that's what George and I are going
to offer you that's they want know
that's the expertise that you come for
here on the Ramsay show all the ladies
in the lobby like that they thought that
was funny well Ken I'm a parenting
expert you are I've had a baby for 6
weeks now by the way how's your sleep
not great if I'm going to be honest I'm
holding it together with an Americano
and a prayer today okay all right it
gets better thank you it gets better uh
but boy I'm glad I don't have to worry
about bottles and diapers so many
bottles yeah but I get to teenagers
whole different level of stress so just
you young parents you know you're going
to trade the physical exhaustion for
emotional exhaustion that's what's ahead
for you parents of teens hey Financial
Peace University is the fastest way to
beat debt and build wealth it's not my
opinion it's not George's opinion George
do we have the proof or not uh I mean 10
million people doing it with success I
feel like is enough proof for me person
bad not bad case study there I'll take
it uh so FPU that's what we call
Financial Peace University is the most
successful personal finance class in the
world it's help millions of people as
George said get out of debt and become
Millionaires and stop worrying about
money over nine weeks this class teaches
you everything you wish you'd learn
about handling money including budgeting
investing real estate and more and the
best part of fbu is the community Stacy
and I have led multiple classes it is a
special special thing to realize I'm not
alone in this going through this with
people who have the same goals and get
this the average FPU graduate is debt
free George in 2 years or less
impressive tell them where to go George
ramseys solutions.com FPU to get started
and if you're thinking well I I've heard
the show I've read the book I'm telling
you you go through these nine classes
about nine hours of content with
accountability and community and you
stick with it it changes you and so if
you've been like hey I've been listening
to you guys for a long time haven't
really done it take that next step and
if your spouse isn't on the same page
this is the best thing you can do I
agree to get them on that same page
instead of using Dave as a cuss word in
your house uhoh there you go all right
let's go to Los Angeles where Liz awaits
Liz how can we
help hi um my husband and I have three
kids we're totally debt free and we have
over $100,000 saved in cash probably
going to be able to save another
$100,000 in the next year we are
currently renting from my in-laws their
house um for super super low cost and
they have no intention of raising it in
the next you know 20 plus years is it a
good idea if we offer you buy the house
off of them is the borrower still slave
to the lender if they give us a discount
on the house or I I just don't know if
it's a good idea or not well would they
give you a discount has this been
floated so we haven't actually got to
sit down and talk with them yet but the
idea is that either we would inherit it
later on um but I really I don't want to
wait that long to just wait to see if we
inherit it um and so I'm thinking that
we'd be able to at least get some sort
of a discount if we were to buy it okay
what would the terms be have you talked
to them about this at
all no so right now we're just renting
no so they have no like have they even
offered hey yeah we we'd be willing to
sell
it nope they've just talked about
renting it this is all hypothetical
there's a lot of hypotheticals here
which we can't get too far with that
what do you think theet
yeah I think the house is worth probably
700,000 okay what's this discount that
you got in your head nobody else knows
about so with the with the they're
inheriting their their parents' house um
and so they were basically saying that
like once this house is either paid off
um like on their mortgage that we'd be
able to either live in it and only pay
them like a tiny bit or get like uh I
don't know my husband is basically like
wanting to to just rent it forever and I
want to offer to buy it since I feel
like we have the money to buy it um well
you haven't giv me the price what do you
think the discount price is and by the
way these are your in-laws I'm guessing
yes yes expence okay great so what is
this discount price you have in your
head that you'd like your hubs to float
up the
ladder even if it was like $5,000 off or
or even just like the fact that we'd be
able to buy it directly would be kind of
like getting a discount because in
California I feel like we couldn't buy
anywhere else I don't know why you feel
so stuck with this house all for a a
less than a 1% discount $5,000 is I
thought you were going to throw like a
100,000 at me for starters why why is
this house special to
you um I just feel like it's the best
deal we're going to get around this area
let's say it's not a deal let's say they
sell for market rate would you rather go
buy buy another $700,000 house that fits
your needs better that you love more if
you're not renting at a discount anymore
we really do love this house and you're
wanting to stay there for a long long
time yes feels like the hubs wants to
rent it until Mom and Dad pass on and
then he then whatever happens happens am
I am I taking too much Liberty with that
no he wants yeah that's what he wants to
do he wants to invest the money that
we're saving on really cheap rent um
I kind of like that deal
myself they're not really yeah George
well that issue with that I like that
move there's a few Avenues I eventually
want you to become homeowner so the idea
of we're going to rent for 30 years just
to invest i g a rent for 30 years how
old are his
parents they are only like 60 so I I
really do think it would be at least a
good here's my thing if you own it
you're going to also own the
appreciation so what happens 20 years
from now and you're done done renting
and they go all right we'll sell it to
you it's worth a million now we'll give
it to you for $99.90 and you're like wow
thank you so much for the this is a fair
point that that's also a concern but I
mean is does he know if he's getting the
house in the will is that already
established there's 60 that should
probably be figured out by now
yes um yeah that's what was discussed
obviously like I can't predict what's
going to happen in 25 years are there
siblings involved no no no no no hold on
a second okay sorry George good question
but what I'm saying is is it already in
the will that you and your hubs are
getting the
house it would be split between the
siblings oh well
then nightmare scenario waiting to
happen strike everything I just said I
would not rent the house what's going to
happen is they're all going to go we're
going to we all agree we're going to
sell this thing and take our profits and
move on with our life versus or you guys
are going to have to buy them all out
and come up with hundreds of thousands
of dollars to do this many many years
from now when the house is
appreciated and George it feels like
this could get sticky too if they offer
to buy the house and the siblings are
going oh wait a second we that's in the
will yeah hon I answer questions the way
I would handle them and truthfully I'm
going to take this nice low rent and I'm
going to save up a giant down payment
and just go find another house Y and if
you end up able to buy this house at a
great deal then do it but I would not
put all of my eggs in this basket
because there's too many
variables and it's going to get too
messy and the whole idea of like
business and family getting mixed
already gives me some heartburn and I'd
rather you just be able to own your
situation and not have all this weird
familial drama
involved so you wouldn't invest the
money that we're saving I mean invest is
a strong word I go well how soon are we
going to get a house if it's three years
from now I don't want to invest that
money if we're talking five years from
now then sure 5 to 10 years of time
Horizon we can invest this money and see
a meaningful
return so like if we were to invest in
the next 10 years let's say and we just
continue with this really low rent um
and I would rent for 10 years though I
would rather get you in a house 3 years
from now when you have the money to do
it when you're financially ready you got
a 15-year fix 25% of your take on pay in
the area you want the home you love then
just bite the bullet and get the house
and pay off the mortgage early and you
own your life you're not worried about
what's going to happen with a will and
what the siblings are going to do that
just exhausts me yeah yeah I agree
that's that got a little too complex
there and it just doesn't make any sense
and it doesn't sound like we're going to
get the deal of a century on this house
at a 1% discount you can go find that
you can go negotiate that right now with
a stranger on the Block oh God bless her
or maybe she needs a negotiation class
cuz I I was shocked she threw the well
I'm thinking $5,000 off $1 Bob $1 it's
like let's make a deal right very
interesting yikes all right folks George
has a little bit of heart bur I'll break
out the Tums during the break and we'll
be right back this is the the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me the phone
number to jump in Isle
8825 5225 our scripture of the day comes
from Matthew
6:34 therefore do not be be anxious
about tomorrow for tomorrow will be
anxious for itself sufficient for the
day is its own trouble our quote from
Robert Orban every day I get up and look
through the Forbes list of the richest
people in America if I'm not there I go
to work all right hey little intense
Robert I I didn't know that if that's is
that one of your life goals no I don't
think I'm ever going to get there Ken
I'm okay with that though I mean getting
up every day and checking out the Forbes
list I mean it's a recipe for a lot of
freight nerves I think but I don't know
but nonetheless there it is all right
let's go to New York New York Max is
there Max how can we help hi uh so I
recently invested 20 months ago in a
piece of real estate I got it for
385,000 it's probably worth it's Le at
least half a m today but probably like
half a m to
550 and the problem is I'm 25 years old
and I've been kind of renting out rooms
while living here to friends and
everything's going great but my
co-signer was not a parent or a
girlfriend is actually a person that
I've worked with at a restaurant and she
recently told me that she would like her
name to get off of the loan so that she
could start
uh looking for a piece of real estate
for
herself and my loan is not
assumable and the only way for me to get
her name off is to refinance which would
double my interest rate right now oh
where's my Tums where's the Max Max
Max dude this is like a Dumb and Dumber
sequel how did you guys get into this
mess so you can't afford the house and
this friend is like hey bro I'll sign
for you yeah I'm good for the money
did you not think about what would
happen later on down the line and
whether or not they're going to want a
piece of this and how they're going to
get their name off so I thought about it
and within because I'm um a contractor
type so I thought okay um within two
years I'll be able to refinance and
because I only put about 5% down as you
do when you're broke and can't afford a
house yes and my goal was to work up at
least 20% equity which I'm pretty
positive I have now okay so I I I went
in with the mindset of okay you know
I'll I'll fix this up I'll get the yeah
and that interest rates would stay the
same forever and now uh
oh yeah okay so your only option here is
to refinance to get their name off the
loan and you're saying if I refinance
it's going to double my
payment uh I mean yeah it'll it'll just
definitely um make it higher and I've
you know I've kind of broken even in
terms of renting the rooms out no you're
just broke I mean the whole this
moneymaking scheme of getting roommates
is not panning out you're about to lose
this
house you can't afford it yeah Max have
you run the numbers like when you say go
up a little bit it's
doubling let's say the payment doubles
your roommates keep paying you the same
you're now underwater aren't
you if I don't think I I mean I have one
more room that I can rent and I I was
just about to make pass
and what happens when they don't pay or
when it's
vacant then it's a it's a bad bad move I
know so we've got to look at some other
Solutions here one of them might be we
have to sell this place that was once a
dream has now become the nightmare we
stepped into it too soon too early with
a friend who co-signed who now wants out
of it and uh you know I don't know
what's what's the are they still friends
with you I imagine this is friendship is
not going to last very long it's you
know surpris there's no real hard
feelings with it um she was just you
know under the impression that at that
two-year mark that I would be you know
we'd be ready to refinance and get her
off which I and how many years has it
been it's been um not even two years
it's been 20 months okay and so what is
the payment now and what would it be if
you
refinance so I think the payment now is
close to 2800
and the refinance payment I think
is um he I checked about two weeks ago
but it was I imagine between 34 and
3600 and that's with current interest
rates I think so yeah and that's on a 30
year okay and what are you making right
now with the roommate's
renting So currently 2600 and I have
another room open that I could easily
get 7 to 800 for okay and you haven't
essentially you you've not been paying
much rent at all or no okay the major I
mean when I first got it it was um a
cosmetic you know fixer uper so a lot of
the rooms needed paint and what was your
long-term play on
this my long-term play was to to buy
this house to um kind of just rent out
until I could afford it on my own and
then maybe kind of do the the Burr
method and if I rented this out with you
know either a full family or the people
that are still here I'd be able to do
the same thing on another piece of uh
okay first of all you realize you're in
the hosle business now that's
essentially what you're doing you're
running a hosle and you're about to be
you're living in it with all these
people I got another room come on and
it's just this is wackadoodle I think
for you for this what's your what's your
income every month um every month I make
about four grand
okay so number one you're going to have
to float the
difference as we deal with whatever the
next few months look like so you're
going to have to start paying uh a bunch
of rent I'd sell the house George you
told him to sell the house I I think you
need to get out of this thing I truly
don't think you're going to anyone who's
if you've kind of like you've been
watching the Tik toks about the bur
method and everyone in real estate
business like dude this is the way you
become a real estate Guru trust me well
this is the reality of it yeah but what
run the scenario for him real quick
George
Vision if he sells it right now with
this what would you get out of this if
you sold it you gave your you know do
they get a share with the
appreciation so they actually they only
did this and it it seems crazy this was
someone that was my boss for a really
long time and she wanted 0% you know in
it unless I defaulted and then then then
we would have to kind of
rediscussed did it to help me out of the
goodness of their heart okay so how much
money would you make if you sell it
today for the
550 um on the loan I think I owe about
365 so I would make close to 20000 and
then you'd be out of this mess and you
have actually gotten out of this with
the closing costs and and everything I'd
probably you know that would take
another 20,000 off or so I'd imagine
let's say you walk away with 175 and
you're out of this mess and you're not
having to worry about having six
roommates just to fill the thing and
hope one of them doesn't vacate and hope
you don't have to evict one and hope you
don't have to pay the rent to make up
the difference but right now the
refinancing at the current rates and
paying four grand a month and trying to
deal with this it feels like too much of
a nightmare for as young as you are and
as much success as you could have in the
future okay could you get a cheaper
place if you sold it and put 175 down
the thing is in this neighborhood I'm in
you know within an hour of um Manhattan
there's you know it's very competitive
and it's it's really difficult it's New
York City it's always going to be
competitive Max why did you call us did
you want us to validate what you're
doing or did you are you even open to
what we just told you well I'm I have
the thing I've been um listening into
the show trying to find a similar
situation and I couldn't really I guess
find one and I I figured you guys would
tell me to just sell it but yeah cuz
you're about to have a four grand
mortgage payment and you make four grand
a
month yeah that's the scary part and
you're a landlord you know running a
hostel you're going to be stressed out
of your mind you've got to get out of
jail card here and we're telling you to
take it but I don't know if you care
more about your your your your mental
emotional and Financial Health or
disappointing people on Tik Tok that you
don't even know cuz they told you to do
it it feels like there's this like you
think we're giving you this
unconventional wisdom you got to choose
reality as my friend Dr John deloney
would say and the reality is this was a
risky gamble that did not pay off and
it's time to get out while we still have
our butt speaking of getting out while
we still have our butt this has been a
great hour thank you George Thanks James
Charles and the team for keeping us on
the air to you the audience this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the ramsy baby
steps go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's Ramsey solutions.com and
click get
[Music]
started